Як справи, друзі? Це Київ, Україна. Населення: близько 3,5 тис.
Це відео про ситуацію з коронавірусом
у місті, у країні.
Але якщо ви хочете побачити, що відбувається на вулицях, як це відчувається, як це виглядає,
тоді це відео для вас.
Ми трохи прогуляємося, зайдемо в метро, зазирнемо в кілька різних районів.
Один з них - місце для шопінгу, інший - найбільш жвава вулиця міста.
А потім потрапимо до ... Скажімо так, до чудового несподіваного місця наприкінці.
Як ви бачите, насправді ніхто не носить маски.
Ті, хто носять, виходять з метро.
Тому що зараз це обов'язково.
Кумедно, як все змінилося.
Близько місяця тому, я завжди носив її на вулиці.
Тепер не завжди.
Можна побачити, що тут нанесені позначки для дотримування дистанції.
Вихідний, але тут нікого немає.
Hello! One, please.
Ви можете побачити...
Не знаю, як ви їх називаєте. Виглядає, як ракетка для пінг-понгу.
Ось бабуся, яка керує невеликим центром управління там.
Здається, вони працюють по черзі.
У всіх цих метро є...
Думаю, це адміністратор. Вона спостерігає за нами, тому що
тут досі є цей відгомін радянського впливу,
особливо серед літніх людей.
Камери були під забороною тут донедавна.
Кажуть, що
кількість випадків
різко зросла. Не знаю, що саме це означає
у цьому контексті.
Отже, більше тисячі смертей в Україні.
Тисяча смертей у країні загалом.
Ці показники
є відносно низькими для населення.
Але найбільшу кількість нових випадків
було зафіксовано вчора.
Багато всього відкрилося,
але деякі заходи безпеки посилюються. Наприклад, маленька крамниця біля мого житла.
Ми довгий час могли заходити туди без масок, ніхто не одягав маску.
Тепер вам не дозволять купити нічого, якщо ви без маски.
А ще через штрафи. Штраф - 17 тис. грн. з людини.
Тобто, якщо я піду і придбаю щось без маски - штраф 17 тис. грн.
Це приблизно 640$.
А крамниця отримає штраф
340 тис. грн.
Це приблизно ...
Скільки? Це близько 12 тис. доларів.
Приблизно стільки. Неймовірна сума.
Ось ми біля
ТЦ "Гулівер"
Вам міряють температуру
у торговельному закладі. Думаю, у всіх торговельних закладах.
Не у маленьких крамницях, а в супермаркетах і торгових центрах.
На кшталт цього.
Кожен повинен носити маску тут.
Мушу  казати, що
люди цього дотримуються.
Хоча ми вже пройшли крізь вхідні двері, тут ще одна перевірка.
Стосовно дотримання дистанціїї...
Маю сказати, що тут з цим складно. Не кожен дотримується дистанції.
Виглядає цілком нормально.
Звичайний супермаркет. Хтось у масці, працівники мають на собі маски та захисні екрани.
Це дуже класне поєднання
ресторану та супермаркету.
Велика колекція вин.
Ресторанний бізнес знову розквітнув.
Можна сидіти всередині.
Коли все це почалось, я з дружиною був у Португалії.
Ми провели зиму в Португалії, але ми живемо в Києві.
Президент дав 48 годин для повернення до країни.
Тому ми швидко повернулися, скоротили нашу подорож.
У перший тиждень, не назву це панікою, але ми вирішили подумати про основні потреби.
Зробити запаси їжі, зняти готівку у банкоматі.
Був тиждень, коли тут не можна було отримати долари.
Гадаю, для більшості людей, так?
Усі хвилювалися про те,
що буде завтра.
У США зараз дефіцит туалетного паперу.
Щодо цього, я хотів би сказати: "Придбайте собі біде".
Використовуйте воду, щоб усе помити. Інвестуйте у біде.
Усе зачинено, метро також.
Ці вулиці спорожніли, тут нікого не було.
Лише кілька автівок.
Кожен, хто був на вулиці, носив маску.
Потім вони
закрили парки. Вони сказали, що закрили їх, але насправді
ніхто не дотримувався цих правил.
Це був чудовий час. Тут було тихо.
Нікого навкруги.
Без метро.
Жодного транспорту. А потім поступово відбувалося пробудження.
Цікаво, що тепер
найбільш ризиковано бути на вулиці.
Якщо вірити науці.
Але більше ніхто не хвилюється, як і я.
Нікому не відомо, що відбувається насправді.
Люди були стурбовані через падіння гривні.
1 долар = 26.55 грн.
Що насправді досить непогано.
Коли все це почалося, кожен намагався отримати якомога більше доларів.
Хвилюючись, що
курс гривні різко знизиться, але цього не трапилося.
Взагалі-то, гривня зміцніла.
О, це мій улюблений барабанщик. Цей хлопець неймовірний.
Цей хлопець протсо встановлює свій набір інструментів по всьому місту.
Щодня протягом року.
Можливо, не щодня. Але в усі пори року. Він тут у найхолодніші зимові дні.
Усе самостійно.
Це Віталій. Легенда.
Ось що мені подобається у цьому місті.
Його безпосередність, класний барвистий мікс чого-завгодно.
Радянська архітектура, новітня архітектура, квартирні будинки, які руйнуються.
Барабанщик Віталій, тут можна побачити що-завгодно.
Я зроблю більше відео про місто. Але саме тут, це Майдан.
Це місце, де відбулося протистояння.
Мешканці міста підіймалися схилом до будинку парламенту.
Спецпризначенці стріляли по них.
Варто віддати належне українцям за те, що вони
вміють проводити час просто розслабляючись.
Гуляти по мосту над Дніпром.
Труханів острів.
Це місце в оточенні природи, тут величезний пляж.
Не знаю, чи стрибатиму у воду. Але тут гарно.
Пішохідний міст. Ходімо туди.
Так душевно. Культура вуличних виступів почала повертатися.
Тут відчуття свята. На мосту дуже людно.
Погляньте на це. Вау.
Коли все лише почалося, я їздив на велосипеді по цьому мосту.
Тут було небагато людей.
На відстані близько 20 футів один від одного.
Кожен був параноїком. Усюди панувало відчуття параної.
Воно зникло, це точно.
Сool!
What do you think about coronavirus?
Що ви думаєте про коронавірус?
About coronavirus? Nothing bad.
Про коронавірус? Нічого поганого.
I think everything's gonna be alright. Я думаю, що все буде добре.
Ось так це відбувається.
Що ж, друзі. Це не науковий аналіз того, що відбувається у Києві.
Та ось як виглядає прогулянка містом.
Однак, якщо все це по-справжньому, якщо це реальна загроза, тоді всі ми дуже заразні.
Цікаво, що тут буде через місяць.
Що ж, це завершення,
завершення туру Києвом під час коронавірусу.
Сьогодні тут багато човнів.
Я буду робити
ще більше відео про Україну, тому що я тут і поки нікуди не збираюся.
Якщо ваші
бабуся чи дідусь бажають їх подивитися,
усі відео матимуть субтитри українською.
Дякую, що пройшли цей шлях разом зі мною.
До наступної подорожі!